TH775 FOR ALEX VICTORIOUS.
FOR OUR ENTIRE CREW, I'M
INGRAM IN THE GOALT VERY STRONG
THE DEFENSIVE SIDE
PREDATORS DON'T FIND HIM.
>> CROSBY'S GOAL TIES HIM FOR .
GR
GRANLUND.
DUCHENE ISE
GOTHAT ONE BOUNCING DOWN OR IT'
BLUEGER THAT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. LOW.
THREE SHOTS IN THE FIRST PERIOD
THAT PAD.
LOOK AT THIS!
HIS HEAD IS GOING ONE E H.
SECO
ALONG THE BOARDS.
GRANLUND JOINS THE BEST OF JEAN
FOR KRIS LeTANG.9 SHIFT
MAKES A SAVE!MATHESON HAS A CHA
THAT OUT AND MAYBESHOT TURNED A
BACK TO ZUCKER AND HE GOES TO
THE BACKHAND.
IT GOES OFF THD JOSI TO THE
SIDE OF THE YET.REBOUND AND
RITTICH ABLE TE ICE.
>> Brendan: MARINO IN THE AIR.
GRANLUPOCHMARA.
HE ITHE GOALTENDER
WITH WAS BLOCKED.
PITTSBURGH PENGUINS HAVE LOST
FOUR IN A ROW.Y KAPANEN.E ICE.
>> Brendan: EXTRA ICE TIME FOR